welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the new season on HBO episode 7 has some
major twists and turns most notably the
reveal that one of the characters isn't
who they say they are throughout this
video we're going to be talking about
the twist that blew our minds some of
the big revelations and why Laurie still
though is called Excalibur get it like X
Cal a but never mind we'll get into that
as we go into the breakdown there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the latest episode
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Watchmen episode 7
ok so similar to the prior entry the
latest episode of Watchmen is sort of a
trip down memory lane however where
episode 6 was about Angela's grandfather
will the latest released titled in
almost religious or focuses on Angela
and one of the major characters around
her the episode opens with a documentary
on dr. Manhattan and it chronicles his
humble beginnings before he entered the
intrinsic field generator that ended up
creating him this ends up being tied
into the seventh Cavalry most notably
Joe Keens plan in which he wishes to
duplicate the process that created the
Superman but early on a warning comes
with it as in this glimpse we see how
the world fused the character it said
that whilst dr. Manhattan was a great
symbol for America many also feared him
and the events that transpired in the
graphic novel that led to Ozymandias
having to fake an alien invasion in
order to unite the world is a strong
indicator of just how much that tensions
rose with America possessing a weapon
that no one could really touch it's
because of dr. Manhattan that the u.s.
won the Vietnam War and it's also
because of this rise in fear that the
character ended up going into hiding
although he kept a watchful eye over the
planet on a human level as we find out
in the major twist in the episode that
I'll get into later in the recap now at
the end of Watchmen dr. Manhattan
say that he was going to go off into the
universe and try and create life and no
I have seen some people say that these
are the clowns that posi mandus is
surrounded by personally I believe that
these are inventions of lady true who as
we know specializes in genetics and has
created humans before though the clones
say he gifted us life I think that this
is sort of a creation by the society
that exists on the moon who may have
created their idea of a male guard
mistakingly obviously I don't know for
definite but I think trues genetic
developments are tied in with them
somehow and the deal that she made with
Ozymandias when buying his corporations
after the dark documentary we then
jumped to Saigon to see Angela's
childhood most notably what inspired her
to become sister Knight similar to
Batman who was inspired by Zorro
angela is influenced heavily by pop
culture and adopts the bright almost
comedic depiction of them in film and
media into a real-world format that as
we know often comes with a dark side to
it similar to Batman Angela or rather
sister Knight was born out of tragedy
and like most superheroes her parents
the ones that she cares for a stripped
away at an early age which means that
she must adopt an almost
larger-than-life persona in order to
provide protection for herself mentally
in what could be a very vulnerable
situation it's the dr. Manhattan parade
and it's clear that a lot of the locals
in the area are heavily upset with the
occupation in the Watchmen universe
after the Vietnam War the country became
a territory of the US and this is why
the flag looks so different to the one
that we have in the real world there's a
man who ends up becoming involved in the
bombing that operates a puppet show
which to me ties back to the line by dr.
Manhattan in Watchmen in which the
character says we are all puppets I can
just see the strings I'm paraphrasing
right now but this image shows that dr.
Manhattan controlled the people but that
the people also have the ability to
control him through their actions even
though everything in Watchmen is
preordained there only exists the
illusion of choice we discover that
Angela's parents were killed by his
suicide bomber and then we join the
character in the present fresh from her
nostalgia trip because she took wills
nostalgia
Angela's memory
all over the place now during the scene
as a pivotal moment between Angela and
her father in which he says people who
wear masks are dangerous we should be
scared of them when asked why he follows
it up with they're hiding something
this really sums up the character for me
who is an expert at hiding all of the
anger and pain that she has went through
in her life and this conversation holds
a lot of weight to it
Angela clearly had a troubled childhood
and even as an adult there is a lot that
went wrong for her however she managed
to move past it due to the system i
persona and this really exemplifies why
a lot of characters and Watchmen have
two personalities one that can bear the
brunt of the darkside whilst the other
one that can seemingly live a normal
life this sort of ties in with the twist
and yeah there's just a brilliant
aesthetic of duality lights throughout
the season Angela's loss of her short
term memory has a constantly asking lady
true the same questions over and over
again and her long-term memory most
notably her childhood is laced with
visions of wills past namely the Tulsa
riots and life as hooded justice true is
trying to fix her memories and thus
throughout Episode seven she constantly
sends her back to the past through neuro
dialysis in order to correct her
recollection of it true is using an
elephant in order to complete the
process as we know an elephant doesn't
forget and this has most likely been
picked because of its strong grip on the
past beyond tests Angela with a sort of
modern-day Rorschach test
but with images instead of ink blots
this highlights how perception is shaped
by our history namely what instances
have shaped us and how some people view
things a certain way whilst others
dunked we saw in episode 4 that BN was
going through a similar treatment to
Angela and that she was inheriting the
memories of her grandmother we learned
that beyond is actually a clone of trues
mother and that true has been slipping
her nostalgia as she sleeps so that her
parents can be there when she completes
her greatest achievement this cements
that the past shapes who we are and how
we view the world which is why true
wishes to shape beyond this way this is
kind of horrifying and it highlights a
true really has difficulty letting go of
her past hence her invention of
nostalgia and the Millennium clock that
she is about to launch true also pays
lip service to the fact that her father
will be there to you and this could
either be dr. Manhattan
or the comedian personally I'm going
with the latter as I believe that true
is the daughter of the comedian and the
pregnant woman that he killed in Vietnam
true could be recreating the comedian as
similar to what she's doing with beyond
and it would be awesome to see him show
up in the finale
there's also mention of what the
Millennium clock does and personally I
believe that this has the ability to see
through time much like dr. Manhattan and
that this will be used to predict future
events true use this in order to see
that she needed to purchase the farm
before the thing that fell from space
crash-landed there and also provided her
with the knowledge of the 7th Cavalry's
attack she knows that they are rising
and creating their own dr. Manhattan and
I believe that with wills help she has
used the clock in order to unearth where
he really is so that he can fight back
Cal tries to visit Angela daily in a
blue car and he wears a blue polo shirt
and blue jeans because we'll get into it
later Laurie also listens back to
Angela's outbursts during her nostalgia
trip in order to get to the bottom of
what's going on the most notable of
these is you can hang yourself now which
is of course a command that will gave to
captain Judd to take his own life which
Laurie later relays to Judds wife PT
investigates looking-glasses bunker and
we also now know for definite that LG
survived due to all the members of the
cavalry being dead and his body being
nowhere to be found he knows that he has
been turned on and this will likely be
lying low because of their double-cross
when questioning judge wife Laurie
reveals that she knows about Cyclops
hoodie justice and has pieced together
the connection between jerd Joe Keene
Cyclops and the seven cavalry the
Laureus marches she's clearly not that
smart divulging all of this to Judds
wife who is actually in on it all and
she traps her with like I want to say
the opposite of an ejecta C trapdoor see
anyway Laurie awakens in the seventh
Cavalry headquarters and Joe Keene
reveals that he is intending to turn
himself in to dr. Manhattan because it's
extremely difficult to be a white man in
America right now now right or wrong
this mirrors wills time has her to
justice in which he pretended to be a
white man in order to fit in
Joe wishes to be the best thing that he
can be in the eyes of society which is
dr. Manhattan
hence the change now Joe and the rest
have obviously got an altered perception
of the world namely because they don't
view themselves as racists but also
because they think this is the way to
change things true wishes to stop them
because she doesn't want the world ruled
by white supremacists and as we see from
all the unanswered prayers in the
episode if someone was to adopt the
moniker of the doc they would be
extremely popular
thus true must get the original in order
to stop him
we learned that Cowell received tole
amnesia after a car accident though we
know that this isn't really the case as
dr. Manhattan cannot be harmed it is
possible at tachyons were used to stop
his view of time simultaneously as we
know from the graphic novel that these
have the ability to do so we discovered
that after the death of her parents
Angela ended up living in an orphanage
in Saigon and that she becomes inspired
to become a policeman by a female
officer who ended up investigating the
bombing that killed her parents one of
the terrorists that was in on the plot
is unceremoniously led away and executed
and this could be a reasoning behind
Angelis choices as she wishes to find
justice in a world that seems to just
want to brush it under the carpet Angela
is adopted by her grandmother June who
as we know from last time was Will's
wife she pays lip service to the fact
that she and her son had a fractured
relationship and this drove him away
from her as we know he was aware of his
father's of the ego and this may have
been a huge factor that pushed him into
fighting in the military Watchmen is
massively about inheritance and just as
Angela seemingly inherited the role as a
masked vigilante June's son could've -
angela has carried the system ID video
as a symbol and she hasn't even watched
it and we learn that will ended up
scoring his son when he was young which
is why he distrusted those that wear
masks Jun promises to take Angela to
Tulsa but unfortunately she dies after
putting her in a taxi in Ozymandias
world the character is on trial for
trying to escape the confines of his
prison and breaking the cardinal rule
thou shalt not leave we see a sketch of
the alien from the graphic novel and
also learn that the character has been
on trial for a year furthermore backing
up that the
the manliest entries are all an
anniversary apart there's a skull and
crossbones behind the game warden which
represents the pirate ship in the black
freighter and when asked if he has
anything to say in his defense
Ozzie farts loudly and it's it's
probably the best moment in the show so
far yes I am very immature Ozzie is
found guilty by way of pig and no we
don't see what happens to the character
I personally believe that as terms of
breaking his agreement he is sent back
to earth and then encased in the golden
statue we saw his craft crash land on
the planet in the opening of episode
four and this explains why true wish to
purchase the farmland in that entry and
from there she captured him and put him
in the statue the episode concludes with
angela discovering a globe that has the
location of dr. Manhattan prep wits on
it here true drops the bombshell that he
isn't listening because he's in Tulsa
pretending to be a human she reveals
that will went too true for help
stopping the seven cavalry who are
planning on creating their own version
of the doc after destroying the old one
she say she knows that the seven cavalry
will launch this attack in an hour which
also adds weight to the abilities that
the Millennium clock has true tricks
Angela into revealing that the latter
knows who he is because she doesn't ask
well who is mainly because she already
knows Angela rushes home watched by
cavalry members and she tells Cal how
much he loves him before hitting him
over the head she says that they always
knew this day would come but that Cal
just won't remember it it turns out that
there was no car accident and that Cal
is really dr. Manhattan who wished to go
back to having a normal life after we
saw the implications that his existence
caused Cal doesn't believe it but she
hammers home the point and pulls out a
ring from his head that is similar to
the dr. man-hands symbol which is also
the symbol for hydrogen as mentioned
earlier I think this may have been made
from tachyons and thus it removed the
characters memories of his life before
the quote-unquote accident will did
mention in episode two that dr.
Manhattan was on earth and disguised as
a regular person and Damon Lindelof upon
announcing the show also said dr.
Manhattan was perhaps just a scared man
sad he would outlive everything so
perhaps this move was to take him away
from the pain that he was inevitably
feeling all of the time the watchmen
graphic novel did say that though doc
was apparently emotionless he gave away
micro expressions that showed he may as
well have been sobbing this also
explains how Angela survived the seventh
cavalry attack as it was just her and
will in the house Laurie's dildo was
also called Excalibur which yet say that
again
ex Cal a bar as in Cal a bar is an
ex-employee Blake probably the best
Easter egg in the show episode 8 will be
fleshing out their first meeting and we
will see that even back then a doc was
trying to hide his true identity as he
picks up a mask off the ground and wears
it when meeting Angela we see there
Angela remained in Saigon as mentioned
last episode and here dr. Manhattan
approached her saying that he loved her
and always had this is because the
character can see the entirety of his
life at once and thus this is how he
knows they will be together
he also picks up two beers which mirrors
is meeting with Janey Slater the first
woman that he fell in love with now I do
think this is all building up to dr.
Manhattan finding the Cavalry's version
of the character and it looks like
Angela may not make it out alive doc
warns her that she will die trying to
save him and this could be the eventual
end for the character though we will see
I love how the show is all slowly coming
together and with just two episodes left
I'm hooked to see what the outcome will
be this just goes from strength to
strength and it's really got me invested
in the outcome
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this episode and if you
agree with the theories in this video
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed it and please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you stay locked to the
channel for more watchmen breakdowns as
the series begins to wrap up we'll be
discussing every episode so it's
definitely worth keeping a tune too
heavy spoilers for more updates as we
get them we also do a podcast called
watching The Watchmen in which we break
down the original graphic novel issue by
issue so if you want to know the full
backstory of the book then make sure you
check it out after this if you want to
come chat to me after the video then
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoin and we have
an awesome communities
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 part 2 boxer blu-ray
which contains Black Panther infinity
war and Game Captain Marvel amour and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on Watchmen in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen on the 15th of December and
the set will be shipped up from then to
him I get surprised it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you